the weekend grabbed
all the lights in tampa and let them
loose on the pepsi super bowl 55
halftime show
but at least
[Music]
between the fireworks bright lights and
even a full moon
the 30 year old singer made sure there
was plenty going on
[Music]
[Music]
the grammy winner took advantage of the
nearly empty stadium seating
which left more than enough space for
him to give us the iconic las vegas
strip
and a big city skyline
[Applause]
[Music]
the weekend was backed up by an amazing
choir with vibes that were equal parts
biblical
and science fiction and that was just on
the surface
he took the audience into an underworld
maze and
invited us to play a game of where's
weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
and when he emerged he took to the
center of the field and conducted his
own take on a marching band before
taking us home with his hit
song blinding lights
with a dancer sporting the weekend's
signature bandages the show
officially became another extension of
his dedicated performance art
all in the name of his album after hours
the weeknd has been committed following
the album's aesthetic at his recent
performances in the past year
the story will continue but definitely
will keep it
pg for the families definitely
thank you jonathan i'll try my best and
when speaking with et's kevin frazier
last week
the weekend teased his unique approach
to the iconic musical event
i want to ask you right off the bat it
it has um been reported that you pumped
millions of your own dollars into this
performance and we now know that it will
come
entirely from the stand so can you tell
us three ways that you will innovate
since you won't have the traditional
stage due to to the covet and
for the safety of the players and
the workers we kind of built the stage
within the stadium
and uh we're also using the field as
well but we wanted to kind of do
something that we've never done before
i'm not going to tell you anything else
because
you'd have to watch on sunday
[Music]
you